v comme une fête quand il est arrivé
le frère danas hariri est finalement
arrivée à l'aéroport de montréal le 23
juin avec sa femme et ses trois enfants
il avait quitté le nord de la syrie il y
a deux ans pour se réfugier au liban
quand tout est prêt tous les papiers au
liban soit prêt et depuis que j'ai
déposé la demande et si au canada ce
après 13 mois des mois de formalités et
ce n'est pas fini
il veut maintenant parrainer sa soeur
ses proches sont dispersés j'ai un autre
frère qui est en turquie que je peux
rien faire pour lui parce que là bas de
bas sport et en plus le baril nage ça
marche pas à partir la turquie khaled
sawaf s'occupe de son ami nabil avoir à
arriver seul en 2013
il croyait pouvoir faire venir sa
conjointe et leurs trois adolescents en
l'espace de quelques mois mais ils sont
toujours coincés à istanbul 08/04/2010
ils vivent d'un double exil leur père à
montréal eut syriens en turquie
les jumeaux ont dû encore reporté leur
rentrée à l'université de nous verser
mcgill et concordia et les frais
d'admission été payés les deux hommes ne
comprennent pas que les démarches ne se
fasse pas en accéléré c'est une
situation qu'un d'un peuple qui est
vraiment en crise en danger pourtant en
janvier
le canada a promis d'accueillir dix
mille réfugiés syriens
au cours des trois prochaines années
depuis le début de 2014
ses 2300 deux d'entre eux qui sont
arrivés au pays
on traite réfugiés comme si c'est des
immigrants stéphane richer qui
représente une centaine d'organismes
chargés de l'accueil des réfugiés crois
que nos gouvernements peuvent accélérer
le traitement des demandes ça déjà été
fait dans le passé notamment avec les
kosovars en 2000 ou qui sont arrivés
sans statut au canada et on les a
traités 5000 d'un couleurs en l'espace
de quelques mois
nabila houara vue d'y croire encore
il a déménagé dans un plus grands
logements en juillet convaincu que ses
enfants seraient là pour la rentrée ici
anne louise despatie radio canada
montréal